[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Alex is
up in San Antonio Texas Alex how can we
help uh yes sir uh good afternoon um I
owe my sister $20,000 that I would want
I would like to pay her back um she loow
me his money earlier in the year and uh
uh we invested the money uh it it didn't
pan out so I was uh calling for your
opinion on getting the loan and if so
what wish would be the best type of okay
hold on a second so so you you you got
your sister to give you $220,000 for
some type of business investment what
was the investment yeah what was it it
was property but it's out of the country
it's in Peru okay we got a little dicey
and it hasn't panned out what does that
mean I would like to pay her the money
well I know what does that mean it
didn't pan out
well we've run into some obstacles legal
obstacles uh evidently the people they
were that we were dealing with weren't
entirely honest with us so the money's
gone and you have no
recourse right what's your how's your
sister taking
it well she's been pretty patient with
me she's she's not harassing me at all
or keep reminding me when were you in
any way when were you supposed to pay
her back like what was tell me the
initial plan CU I'm I'm trying to gauge
um what your timeline is we were
supposed to fa within a couple of months
uh it's been almost a year and it it's
gone out it's gone just a little bit
longer than I would wanted to got it
okay well you're but you're broke you're
broke and you're thinking now I got to
get this monkey off my back with my
sister so I'm going to go get a loone
and I'm then going to just pay the bank
back and I just think that's ridiculous
I'd rather you be spending all of your
time and effort just paying your sister
back you don't need to go to a bank or a
credit union or some private loone shark
type situation where they're going to
charge you enormous interest rates just
start paying her back if could you pay
her $1,000 a month what would need to be
true for you to pay her $1,000 a month
or $2,000 a month could that
happen yes I could pay her a th000
possibly 2,000 if you really discipline
ourselves then start doing it like this
your sister man she loaned you the money
man up start paying it back what was
that patient enough with me and I would
I would prefer to just pay her pay her
because I see you can't pay her 20,000
so pay her what you can because here's
what can happen I want I want to lay out
two sides of this unless you tricked
her right when you said hey sis let me
borrow 20,000 I have this real estate
thing that I want to invest in when you
say the word invest you any person knows
okay there's a chance I could make money
and then there's a chance I can lose
money so she I'm guessing she knew going
in there was a chance that you would
lose this money and if that was the case
she wouldn't get her return back as
quick or she wouldn't at least get the
money that she invested back as quickly
so go ahead so there is part of that
there is part of that that's true you
both agreed on this thing I think it was
a terrible agreement but you both agreed
to it so there is part of that where
it's like okay like you you said you
were investing in this it didn't pan out
so it's going to take a minute to get
the money back I'm afraid of you getting
aan because I think if you get a loan
it's going to cause you to move slower
on this than you need to because as Ken
said the monkey's off your back now you
can just be willy-nilly with it when
it's your sister you're going to you
know move I don't know if I can say you
can move hell on Earth to to get this
money right and so I want that kind of
intensity for you to pay her back
because you don't like this and I like
that you don't like it because that's
what's going to make you move and you
need to move my brother and let me tell
you something if you go get a loan that
interest payment is going to be more
punishment for something that you
already did that was dumb don't multiply
dumb learn from the stupid mistakes
we've all done them move forward start
paying her what you can each month
you'll get through this create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life